all right here with a lot of details and
reaction Missouri attorney general and
Senate elect uh Eric Schmidt is with us
he has been suing the Biden
Administration over social media
censorship okay
did I connect the dots in a way that
makes sense to you because I think it
can get confusing but did the FBI put
their finger on the scales they had this
laptop for 11 months they did nothing
with it uh and then the FBI is telling
every week they're meeting with these
big tech companies and they are saying
to them oh be on the lookout for these
hack and leak operations uh and it may
even be about Hunter we're told they
knew that story was likely going to come
out because they had the laptop and they
knew Rudy Giuliani had it
that's right Sean and also I think this
is a story of the federal government
with all of its vast power and authority
colluding with some of the biggest
companies in the history of the world to
censor Americans uh to uh put their
thumb on the scale as you said of what's
out there what people can actually read
and know about before an election and it
ought to secure uh the bejesus out of
every American I don't care what your
political stripe is I mean this is out
of some dystopian novel and what we
learned we took the deposition of Elvis
Chan the FBI agent last week well here's
what's very clear the FBI had the hunter
Biden laptop story in 2019 they sat on
it they didn't do anything with it they
knew it wasn't hacked material they knew
it was legit
um Miranda Devine of the New York Post
uh said that they had access to her
emails they also knew when this story
exactly was going to be published Elvis
Chan testified that they were having
meetings monthly meetings including
weekly meetings telling to be on the
lookout for hacked and leaked materials
Joel Roth the Integrity guy at Twitter
uh in a sworn affidavit said that in
those meetings they said there's going
to be something potentially something
about Hunter Biden in that story so you
connect all these dots and this was a
backdoor way to affect censorship they
were also advising them on their uh what
their hack and leak or their hack policy
ought to be and you also have the same
guy Jim Baker who was General Counsel of
the FBI in 2016 and then general counsel
of Twitter in the fall of 2020 is
clearing those Elon Musk that the
Twitter files he was the one saying put
the brakes on this so the FBI was very
involved in it again this is very
concern turning for our Republic we
believe in free speech we believe the
first amendment is the Beating Heart of
the Constitution and when you have the
federal government and law enforcement
acting in this way it's shocking all
right so this guy yo Roth is Twitter's
former head of site Integrity he's the
one that said he was meeting weekly with
the FBI and they were meeting with other
big Tech organizations let's fast
forward to the FBI and their special
agent Elvis Chan who you and uh I
believe interviewed last week and he
said in a lawsuit that the Biden
Administration organized the meetings
and in fact uh your solicitor general
said Chan said the FBI warned Twitter to
be on guard for hack and leak and that
this guy Roth confirmed that hack and
leak oh be on the lookout for something
about Hunter Biden if you see it it's
probably going to be fake isn't that
what they did is that what the FBI
operation did yeah yes and the FBI knew
that that wasn't a hacked uh you know
hard drive they knew that that was legit
they had that computer in their
possession for a year but were laid the
groundwork for months that this could be
something that comes up in in Roth it
specifically Mitch's in October so again
they lay the groundwork uh for this to
be censored material and when the issue
comes up and they know by the way the
date in which according to Miranda
Devine in which this is going to be
published so the groundwork have been
laid and Twitter did what Twitter did
and so now the what's what's confounding
the left is all these pieces of the
puzzle now are coming together and
through our previous deposition of
Anthony fauci through the discovery
we've already gotten of the specific
portal the government had with these big
Tech Giants to censor Americans uh you
know Banning people de-platforming
people silencing people you know big
Tech was doing the bidding of big
government they were working with the
help of the FBI they would be instructed
almost by the FBI let me ask you this is
said if you shut down dissenting voices
that is by its very definition election
interference when he was asked why the
media is acting like this is a nothing
Burger he had a great answer he said
because they're all complicit in lying
to the American public uh and that
they're acting as the propaganda arms of
the democratic party do you agree with
Elon Musk is all of that true did our
FBI put and big Tech and the media did
they all sort of collude together to put
their thumb on the scale to prevent the
American people for seeing a story about
corruption with Joe and Hunter Biden in
the weeks leading up to the 2020
election that could have if the people
knew about it that could have impacted
the result of that election sir
that yeah this story should have been
out there there was no reason for this
to be bottled up and the FBI laid the
groundwork I mean this was Elvis Chan's
sworn deposition he said that they were
having monthly and weekly meetings they
knew the the hunter Biden laptop wasn't
hacked material and they specifically
said according to Twitter's Integrity
guy Roth that uh they mentioned the
hunter Biden Story I mean that's just
that's that's nuts in our our federal
law enforcement has no role in this they
shouldn't have anything to do with this
uh government shouldn't be censoring
people government shouldn't be telling
these platforms what they can publish
and what they can't publish and also an
interesting tidbit here Sean that came
out of that deposition was Elvis Chan in
his deposition also believes that this
was influenced by Democrat members of
Congress and their staffers going to
Silicon Valley saying that they need to
affect their content uh moderation
policy or else
Mr Attorney General senator-elect Eric
Schiff uh Schmidt of Missouri thank you
by the way uh bringing this to
Washington I think you got your work cut
out for you thank you for being with us
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else